je crois que c'est quand je suis assis à
côté des usa parce que je comprends rien
à ce qu'elle dit autrement le meilleur
moment c'est quand je suis pas là il est
meilleur moment si c'est un petit pas
loin du chocolat qu'il fallait ça pour
moi c'est payant condamné le pire moment
de l'année c'est quand j'ai reçu du
chocolat c'est arrivé qu'une fois deux
fois 0 6 2 fois du chocolat donc
chroniqueurs préférés c'est top team ico
je trouve que j'ai c'est sûr il est
inattendu il est bienveillant les
rigolos il s'endort santé plaisir
il est vraiment à l'ouest il pas
carriériste ça mec sain normal même si
l'appareil il faut s'achète encore les
appareils photo non mais avec un
objectif spécial tu peux placer des
photos entre les poteaux que tu prends
la fin il a acheté des terres positif je
suis attendu cette merde
fort boyard c'est super au top c'est
qu'ils genre tu prends une photo tu
crois que tu tu as appris qu'une photo
et sur ta photo ou bien en place et une
autre mais c'est chiant parce que tu
prends une photo que nago de karina
week-end à temps partiel en photo et à
montiel à l'arrivée c'est collé savoir
mercredi que des preuves
méchant et que pas être méchant non
salées 7 et font des éditions pas fourni
non pas fondées bobine ça tout le monde
enfin cette année ça monte en grade je
veux dire dans lanarca les wagons
déconnade
oui mais aussi dans le fond mais dans
l'info donc c'est intéressant je
retourne c'est toujours bon moi je viens
pas trop souvent mais c'est bien quand
je suis là ça fait plaisir
d'abord de les retrouver tout et puis de
retrouver cette ambiance de délire mais
c'est quand même si rynnas album
tranchant et tout état qui ont fait
voyant ses sales gosses cyril l'antenne
on a été préféré c'est plutôt je sais
pas j'ai beaucoup rire les caris
franchement charisme où il passe il vous
rappeler la séquence
il ya des coups pas au téléphone et
évidemment ils se sont un peu chambré
même beaucoup et est un moment charisme
qui était assis à côté de moi n'avaient
pas compris non plus parler de sa grand
mère
dans sa saisine et car ici qu'est ce
qu'il a dit et moi je vais taper sur
l'épaule il ya des tas grand mère n'a la
salle et c'est évidemment ça vous fait
rire et à la fois sur des réseaux et
cyril alors il a explosé derrière ça je
m'en souviendrai longtemps mais j'aime
en général tous ces rapports que je me
faisais rappeur que je ne connaissais
pas et que je découvre avec plaisir
maquilleuse tout sa grand mère tu fais
du cinéma ont ralenti dans la salle de
sport il n'y avait pas grand mère
alors à priori et que tu t'attends
l'année prochaine j'attends rien
j'attends rien de ma vie mon âge tu vas
encore parler de johnny en a marre abel
des classes unis dans le coup ça peut
durer dix ans donc je crois tu es signés
pendant 10 ans on m'a dit bernard
bazille bernard alors c'est très
important la compacité à figurez-vous
par décret présidentiel
il sent que ça va être chaud du 2
février est ce que tu penses que ce sera
la dernière année de tpm p 500 oui ce
sera sûrement la dernière année des pnb
mais ça sera magistral ça un final
explosif
chez moi je resterais chez mobile à sur
mer et j'insisterai à différents
festivals de théâtre et de l'usiné
j'irai mais qui n'osent pas nous toucher
à georges ça fait encore plus nombreuses
et l'année prochaine
et arrêtez de dire que ce fait décidé de
pousser font casser la tête
j'étais au téléphone by top 10 séances
d'uv pour ce report